We should just tell
the truth quickly.
They're gonna cut us off.
There are some really
bad things going on here.
We cannot accept
a culture of silence.
We have some breaking news
right now.
Moments ago,
UBA's national feed
abruptly cut to a test pattern.
We have to stay
together on this.
All the attention
is going to land on me.
Careful what you wish for,
right?
♪ Start spreading the news ♪
♪ I'm leaving today ♪
♪ I want ♪
Let me make this simple.
We have to get Alex back.
She publicly left the show.
♪ New York, New York ♪
I don't want to.
I'm not coming back.
They hurt me. This is about them
doing things behind my back.
It's all gonna work out.
Don't tell me
it's gonna work out.
There is a cost
to success and fame.
-You're a dead man.
-Said the corpse.
There will always be a part
of me that wants to be liked.
I never wanted to be
this person.
Things are supposed
to get better.
Everything changed in a minute.
The whole world changed.
I thought we were a team.
Honestly, Bradley,
a friendship with you
seems like
a bountiful journey.
♪ If I can ♪
You talked to Mitch.
Did he tell you that?
People deserve
to know the truth.
Nobody likes a gossip.
There's been
a lot written about
The Morning Show
and a lust for ratings
that made even the worst
behavior permissible.
Do you feel that the important
issues have been addressed?
♪ It's up to you New York ♪
♪ New York ♪